bang bang
lunch money time tuesday well while
she's trying to get rich
russell's just trying to get her lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent polina evilova pompliano
p-i-m-p
pimp in the house uh what kind of shirt
is this a dom
uh 101 dalmatian shirt no it those are
little
crosses or like stars x's x's
x's x and me out of the picture all
right don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by blockfy you can earn up to
8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account
duh way higher than you're getting in
your bank account there's risk go do
your research
i am an investor in the company and a
happy happy user
you can also buy and sell crypto or you
can give them crypto and they'll give
you
a us dollar loan against your collateral
go check them out at
blockfy.com lunch money
slash slash slash whatever
slash blockbuy.com lunch money
all right what is up there's a lot going
on with tick tock
one one of the things is first of all
microsoft's trying to buy it then
trump's trying to get the treasury
involved
[Music]
but third of all the chinese state media
slams us
is a rogue country for its planned smash
and grab
tick-tock can we do something special
for this topic today
can we do both sides of the argument
great let's do both sides of the art
let's start with the u.s the u.s side of
the argument
yes which is hey you take tons of
sensitive data
hold on a second say that it hasn't been
proven that they
grab the data and feed it to the ccp
oh it's proven that they're getting the
data but it's not proven that they're
giving it what if
what if we're doing all this and they're
not even giving it to the government
it's not that they have to do it it's
the possibility of them doing it okay
right uh it's kind of like you know
google you say like don't be evil
but if they have the ability to be evil
then they're they're
so they're taking the data we're not
happy yes
and so the u.s basically says look uh
you've got a great firewall you don't
allow american technology companies into
china why are we letting your cut
your companies here and also why are we
letting
a chinese company get all of this data
and we can and we can't
check to see what they're doing with it
now on the flip side
wait hold on it's kind of like when
you're little and you your friends like
i'm not going to let you play with my
ball and you're like yeah but how can we
always play with my balls when i'm going
to take my ball away
something like that yeah like playground
economics kind of
um but the chinese are basically saying
wait a second
you're basically uh being a bully
and you're gonna steal the us operations
of one of our most valuable technology
companies
uh we haven't done anything wrong and
this is complete that are you
yawning no she slept in today she
shouldn't be yawning
and so look at her laughing uh and so
the whole idea is
um while that's going on uh china's
gonna spin this as like the united
states is rogue it's a smash and grab
they're they're stealing our company
blah blah whatever right
what ultimately is going to kind of be
the needle here that that
threads the line is there's probably
truth in both arguments
right and that's the part that's a
conversation people don't want to have
which is
do you guys have to do something you
can't allow a chinese company to get all
the sensitive data
right but at the same time uh the whole
idea of like banning or forcing an
acquisition whatever
like everyone's gonna debate what's
right what's not the craziest part
is the uh is the president saying you've
got to pay the u.s
treasury and so the two sides of that
argument that are really interesting are
one
there's a bunch of people who say uh
that's
uh basically like a uh extortion right
or it's a bribe to the u.s government
basically microsoft if you pay money to
the treasury you're bribing the us
government to approve the acquisition
that like you shouldn't do that there's
another set of people right
there's a recent techcrunch article that
made the argument no the payment to the
us
government should come with uh
some sort of regulatory clarity post
acquisition so there's a bunch of
privacy concerns we've seen companies
like microsoft facebook and others have
to pay
big big fines to the ftc and stuff in
the past and so this is essentially
uh some sort of fine is how you could
look at it
but it's not gonna go to the ftc it's
gonna go to the us treasury instead
again i think that uh it would be very
unprecedented for there actually be a
payment to the us government in a
situation like this
but we will see what happens speaking of
fines
twitter warns about possible 250 million
dollar
ftc fine it on monday the company said
that it
expects to lose as much as 250 million
for using personal information users
provided for security purposes
to target advertising instead
here's another company using data
so it's like good no go ahead no go
ahead
although sometimes like i'll be talking
to my friends and i'll show them
how they can turn off like the things on
twitter for privacy so they don't get
targeted and instagram
and they're like yeah but i kind of like
being targeted with
specific ads to me i don't want just
random ads and i'm like well
well and this is a fallacy i think that
people have
most of these companies are not selling
your data they're not actually selling
your email address or selling your um
you know information what they're doing
is they're using it for ad targeting
so they what they're they're saying to
an advertiser is hey you give us your ad
inventory and then what we're going to
do or give us your ad
um kind of collateral and then what we
will do is we will place that in front
of people
that we think are most likely to want to
see that stuff i got rothy's ads for
like three months
until i bought it and you bought a pair
right exactly so i think that
uh what's the difference between what
tic tocs doing and what twitter is doing
really it just comes down to what are
they trying to do with the information
if you're targeting ads like these
companies all continue to look like
he still doesn't like it so no no they
could see you get in trouble but i'm
just saying
uh the belief with tick tock is that the
data is not going to be used for
targeting ads
can be used for other nefarious purposes
right all right what's up with pinterest
all right so i like pinterest this is
one of my favorite companies not just
because i'm a user but also because it's
doing well
and the ceo is not an egomaniac um okay
so pinterest looks to implement u.s
success overseas
i don't care it's international that
wasn't a real yawn i can tell
really on from a mile away so
pinterest looks to implement u.s success
overseas as
international user base grows so
um the international revenue made up 15
of pinterest overall revenue in the
second quarter up from
nine percent a year ago ceo ben
silberman said
it's very interesting to me how
pinterest feels like it's uh
this massive social media company but
it's flown under the radar for so long
because he didn't really talk about it
like he he ben silberman does not do a
ton of media
so it's easy to as you read an article
of him on jim cramer's fashion no but
that's that's
new or what mad money or whatever it's
called yeah so they did 270
uh million dollars in q2 so they do
about a little over a billion dollars in
annualized revenue
which is uh small compared to a lot of
these other social media companies
but still it's a billion dollar revenue
business um
and it just feels like they don't get
nearly as much uh kind of coverage as
everybody else
people don't understand pinterest they
kept trying to be
they kept trying to say it it's a
bulletin like it's women you know
posting
it's not like that at all people plan
vacations on there they
shop on there um the smartest thing that
pinterest did is hire a bunch of people
from
google and make the search part
of pinterest amazing absolutely amazing
so
they have 416 million monthly active
users worldwide
which is a 39 increase
year over year which is incredible
you're talking about a business that
literally has 400 million users and does
a billion dollars in revenue
so the two things are like one why do
you make so little money with your 400
million
monthly active users maybe that's why no
one's talking about you
uh and then two is 400 million monthly
active users is a massive massive number
all right let's get into the big one
today the reporters what's up with them
yet another reporter is leaving her job
over
concerns of um
poor ethics and bad process
and just overall divisiveness her name
is
ariana peckery peccary
and so the context here and then i'm
going to let pelina go on a monologue
there's been a number of high-profile
resignations
from various uh publications or or
uh media companies so you had barry
weiss leave the new york times you had
andrew sullivan
leave the new yorker and now you have uh
this woman
leave msnbc and each one of those three
people and there's been others but those
three are the ones that stick out my
head
have chose to leave not quietly
but instead write pretty scathing
resignation letters that they published
publicly to
raise the um kind of the warning flag on
one specific issue which is the pursuit
of truth around what journalism was
built on
has fallen to the wayside in favor of
clicks
and views and readings and consensus so
it's basically like
they're like everyone like there's taboo
subjects now that you can't talk about
even if they're true because the goes
against the consensus
advertisers want a specific narrative
like all of these people are colluding
for something so what do you think you
you've worked in a real news room you
were a real journalist
i've also worked at a cable news network
we all know
know as cnn all right um hold on i just
want to say that the woman
she wrote my colleagues are very smart
people with good intentions the
is the job itself it forces skilled
journalists
to make bad decisions on a daily basis
so what's your take my take is that i
get it
do you agree with what was she saying
absolutely no i think i think that
there's going to be kind of like a
reckoning at some point there's a lot
of media organizations who prioritize
uh clicks page views and ratings i
sorry for whoever watches cnn and fox in
msnbc i do not consider
cable news networks journalism that is
not journalism that is pure
entertainment
and she even says um she said somebody
a very capable senior producer once said
our viewers don't really consider us the
news they come to us for comfort
if you watch msnbc you're watching them
for us because you have a specific
political viewpoint if you're watching
fox same thing
um i just i i hate that stuff i don't
like people telling me something i
already
think and i don't like people yelling at
me about why i'm wrong
i like to find news and facts and real
stuff
what do you think the solution is read
no associated press and reuters
sorry but are they not biased as well
no they're new they're wire services
they're more they're very much like here
are the facts and they
feed it to cnn and whatever and they
take it and they
run with it okay and then i guess as
part of that
um what about with like video like
that's the thing i keep going back to
is how do we change
the video content so people who are
trying to produce the news is it
something where you get
uh kind of a republican and a democrat
or people on either side of an issue and
they come and you have a long-form
conversation to discuss about it or
there's a solution the problem is if you
look cnn and fox
aren't doing original reporting when's
the last time you saw a fox
investigation or a cnn investigation
like
it's very extremely rare they usually
take what's already in the news
in the talking heads just spin it and
talk about it and whatever
and comment on it what's easier than
doing investigative
right and because it's news and it's 24
hours and whatever
i'm i think the days of i'm gonna sit
down i'm gonna write an article i'm not
just gonna aggregate it from another
news source or a blog
i'm going to start with experts and
market participants and people who are
in the industry
to tell me what they think and i'm going
to do an array of voices
and then present the facts as i see it
and the reader can make
an informed uh decision for themselves
that's not happening at all anymore it's
just
more and more i think a lot of
organizations because they're
prioritizing clicks and ratings
are working to uh make us more divisive
and i love what she says she's like
the news is blaming the people oh
they're uneducated they're the problem
they're not doing this and it's like no
no you're the problem
like stop blaming the people you're not
informing them how you should be
so facts big facts right there coming
straight from paulina
uh the other thing is uh i wrote
yesterday
about the difference between journalists
bloggers and market participants
and uh one of the key things i think to
all of this
is uh there's a bunch of bloggers
masquerading as journalists and what i
mean by that is
most of the media companies in the
written form were losing
attention on the internet uh and
it's because it's hard to write uh
there's no salacious headlines
if you do just pure journalism without
clickbait without opinion
um with really kind of just confirming
facts and and
talking to people it doesn't do well on
the internet right
and because it's not um uh kind of
salacious enough and so what they did is
they when they hired a bunch of
bloggers to now work at these media
organizations and pretend like they're
journalists but they're just bloggers
so blogging actually goes back uh uh
goes
back a little while ago if you guys read
the book by ryan holiday it's called
trust me i'm lying confessions of a
media manipulator
ryan holiday actually used to be a media
strategist for these clients like
including authors
uh american apparel companies whatever
so he what he would do
is he would plant stories because he
knew
that a lot of big organs news
organizations were desperate for stories
so he would plant stories and blogs
and then the reporter would read the
blog and be like oh my god here's what i
found out about american apparel and he
would
basically manipulate the whole process
it's a fascinating and infuriating book
but
it's worth reading watch what you read
you know what you should be reading the
profile read the profile.com improve
your content diet today
all right what's up with virgin galactic
oh really oh yeah
virgin galactus she shook because i just
gave her a plug right there read the
profile.com
virgin galactic supersonic jet would go
from nyc to london in two hours
shattering concord record first of all
i feel like we talk about this all the
time and it just never happens like
supersonic jets
okay well that's great okay can you stop
um but supersonic like when is this
gonna happen it's never gonna happen we
just keep talking
the company well read what does it say
that what's gonna happen it doesn't say
well what does it say it doesn't say
when it's going to happen it literally
does not they announced their
partnership with rolls royce
how about that you're going to be
rolling in a rolls-royce supersonic jet
to develop a supersonic jet like do you
know how long that takes come on richard
be capable of carrying between nine and
19 passengers and would cruise at an
altitude of 60 000 feet
all i want to know is who's the first
rapper that gets the rolls-royce
supersonic jet in the video
that's what that's that's why they're
building that plane it's not to take
anybody anywhere it's just to put it in
the music video
let me flex on you real quick i
interviewed richard branson once
okay next um who's that
kidding all right lastly positive news
time he found this one
this i love this story a ten-year-old
minnie monet
fetches tens of thousands for her
paintings and donates all the money i
i have a lot of faith in the next
generation so she's a 10 year old
in england and she paints these quote
stunning
floral landscape they are stunning and
they are floral
uh and they sell for up to ten thousand
euro uh and she literally takes all the
proceeds and she donates it
yeah and like yeah the photos are cool i
mean i i'm not a
uh or critiquer but
for a young kid they're really damn
impressive
and uh when she sells them she literally
yeah there's one of the paintings right
there
so she does things like that and she
literally turns around
and she saw donates all the research and
all that stuff
like wow i wish that the adults acted
like the kids
do you think that her parents are making
her donate the money no
i actually think that kids are usually
more
selfless selfless than adults of course
like what bills does she have
she ain't got no bills i agree but 10
year olds all she's worried about is
like can i watch tv for an extra 30
minutes before bedtime she
she started painting four years ago when
two of her grandparents were diagnosed
with cancer and she painted a picture to
cheer them up
so then she started um to be displayed
at local gallery and auction their
auction for cancer charities i think
that's awesome
yeah by the way if i was 10 and i had 10
000
i've been popping i've been the richest
kid on the playground
y'all gonna see me come up in a big
wheel i'm gonna have all the basketballs
fly new shoes might even bring everyone
mcdonald's
like i would be the king of the
playground i'm trying so hard not to cry
right now because stories like that get
me and he knows it
but you're gonna cry because the girl's
painting and donating the money
all right what's your joke we have two
minutes what do you call a sad cup of
coffee
paulina why'd you laugh
see how funny i am a sad cup of coffee
uh
i'm gonna call it
milky what is it
a depresso you don't get it because you
call it
an expresso it's espresso but this is
depresso
are you making fun of the way that i
talk yes literally the people in the
comments are
like it's not egg especially it's
especially
hey people in the comments it's not
expresso when you get your own youtube
show you can talk however you want i
like how i talk all right
what is it oh also whatever what is it
depresso
no no how do you say the word i spread
especially especially
what do i say especially yeah you say
egg just because i'm hungry i'm thinking
about food you know
like hey let me get some eggs special to
the commenter who said
that i need some sun you'll be looking
fast you'll be looking like casper if
you were in new york city for five
months straight let me come at me
i i have more of a tan than you all
right guys that's it for lunch money
today
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right we appreciate you guys
watching every single day
learning that's all this world is about
it's just learning i don't have to
sneeze
we're all gonna die one day so learn
here while you're here
see you okay bye bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block life's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends